[Music]
so I noticed with alan arkin and
everybody's having a hard time with the
oscar and what to do with it so i came
up with this backstage it's a ellen
oscar bjorn and what it is when you go
to the parties later and you have your
hands-free to shake hands or drink or
smoke or whatever and still be able to
show off your oscars so i'll be selling
them backstage later or on ellen tv.com
a little later on anyway here to present
the award for best costume design please
welcome two of the stars of The Devil
Wears Prada Emily Blunt and Anne
Hathaway
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening we're here to present the
Oscar for costume design and there is no
one in this room more qualified than the
two of us or just me leave the character
behind them I'm Meryl I love you
why doesn't she have a cappuccino did
you get her cappuccino so what you were
gonna get you look a she's smiling is
that it doesn't bother her
[Applause]
look at what we'll get it for you after
this this year's nominated designers had
to struggle with one singular problem
how to dress a queen a diva or an
empress
[Music]
in curse of the golden flower each young
man designed a collection of xinhua Zuri
there was based on traditional imperial
court where crossed with sexy modern
influences
[Music]
[Applause]
a world away in the Queen consulate
O'Boyle provided elizabeth ii the
variations on formally informal clothes
dressing her majesty and concert for the
hunt the ball keys and other affairs of
state to me
[Music]
[Applause]
in The Devil Wears Prada Patricia Field
creates a fantastic array of
contemporary culture a parody of every
dish the fashion world is serving up to
anyone who dares to eat it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Sharon Davis's challenging Dreamgirls
was to recreate the Motown glam and
glitter of the 60s contrasting that
glitz with what the people in the street
were wearing at the same time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in marie antoinette's milena cannon era
found inspiration in the foods of the
French Court specifically the desserts
her costumes were literally eye candy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to why don't you say
it everything sounds better with a
British accent milena Canon arrow
[Music]
this is the third Academy Award and
eights nomination from Elena cannon
arrow she took home her first two Oscars
for Chariots of Fire and Barry Lyndon
[Music]
[Applause]
well very happy to be here but also very
frightened him to be here so in one way
I wanted to get this doll and another I
was frightened but thank you so thank
you very very much
I want to thank Francis first of all for
introducing me to Sophia when we are
doing cotton club and she was this and
now she's my director I think she did a
wonderful movie a movie set like a poem
and she's fired me I haven't prepared
the speech so I have to hurry up because
marshal my husband said have to get out
here quickly so I want to thank
everybody who had anything to do with
this movie without them I wouldn't be
here
and it's a communal effort therefore
thank everybody very very much I want to
dedicate this award first of all to mama
then who had son and Stanley Kubrick my
great master without them I will be here
thank you
[Applause]